[Música]
el hambre en máximos históricos en
Afganistán las estimaciones del programa
mundial de alimentos sitúan que 4
millones de niños madres embarazadas y
lactantes estarán en situación de
desnutrición en 2023 sermina y su hijo
son un ejemplo
mi hijo se enfermó porque todos los días
cuando su papá sale a trabajar no gana
lo suficiente para darle de comer cuando
logra comprar algo de pan comemos si no
hay muchas veces que pasa el día sin que
podamos comer
pero esta situación va más allá de niños
y madres cerca de la mitad de la
población afgana está pasando hambre
Entonces desde agosto de 2022 Afganistán
ha estado en la cima En la cima mundial
de los países con un consumo de
alimentos insuficientes
el hambre también se ha visto agravada
por la ola invernal que vive Afganistán
es el invierno más frío en 15 años con
temperaturas alcanzando los menos 34
grados
mis hijos están congelando en casa no
tienen ropa abrigada para ponerse y
desafortunadamente este invierno es muy
frío y nuestra condición es muy mala
más de 160 personas han muerto por la
ola de frío y las hospitalizaciones de
niños han estado cerca de duplicarse
Respecto a 2022 los centros de salud No
dan abasto
aunque nos entregan una cantidad de
medicamentos a través de algunas ong
benéficas Todavía falta personal médicos
especialistas enfermeras y el flujo
constante de pacientes crea un gran
desafío para nosotros
el talibán tomó el poder en 2021 la
economía se derrumbó en una caída que ha
ido acompañada de múltiples desastres
naturales